head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard
charts New York Post 12,000 migrants
cross Southern Border in a single day
Tuesday highest total
ever dude these videos are insane I
don't know if you guys have seen them uh
and the federal government is doing it
intentionally 100% y yeah so why why
would there be a Florida Alliance in
this film because the southern states
say you have you you have you have
inflicted this upon us yeah yeah I mean
it's it's funny when they they call it
like the Border crisis like a hurricane
is a crisis like you didn't see that
coming but this is 100% the plan of the
Democrats and every single Democrat this
isn't just Biden at the federal level
every single Democrat in the house in
the Senate they are part and parcel of
this they have voted for it they've
voted against border security right now
they're going to the mat and they're
fighting against the Republican plan to
actually secure our border and it's I
mean we think right now there's 10
million illegals that have come into the
country 118 15 to 16 maybe yeah and you
know what Chicago's mayor is saying no
we can't it's the Republicans that are
doing it he said it's it's it's this
governor of Texas sending them all here
it's his fault meanwhile Texas is trying
to stop them with everything it has they
Texas just passed a law saying that it's
illegal to enter the state of Texas uh
illegally yeah illegally well because
typically border crossings are a federal
and the argument is Texas has no right
to only the Federal Government Can
Deport to other countries Texas is
basically asserting the right to arrest
and detain anyone and I think what's
going to end up happening is these
people who are coming in and mass in an
invasion and it is an invasion they're
going to be placed in very serious uh
squalor and horrifying conditions the
Democrats will weaponize that and say
Trump is Hitler so this is what they're
building up to when Trump gets elected I
would not be surprised if Trump says
it's time to deport these people and you
end up with camps full of migrants right
the Democrats then say oh no we warned
you he's Hitler yeah exactly well and
the Democrats I mean their their plan's
very diabolical they want a mass wave of
illegal immigrants they can pump into
all these different Urban centers so the
next time there's a census they can
count heads and from that they can make
new legislative seats I mean it's a pure
power play and then ballot Harvest their
way there they're eroding any kind of
verification for citizenship to be able
to vote in elections like in my state in
Washington and they don't care about any
of the Carnage that comes along with
that I mean 18,000 Americans have been
killed by fentanyl in the last couple
years that's come across the southern
border and like the Democrats don't even
talk about that I mean that's the number
one killer in our in our district right
now which is Absolut insane W I truly
believe that the the fact that the media
is so uh is so lock step with the
Democrat me the DNC message that I don't
know that the American people can beat
that kind of
propagandizes to get answers down at the
border wall like by from the border
patrol or anybody like the sheriff's the
only one who can talk about it publicly
honestly I don't think your average
person believes it oh yeah they can't
because the media doesn't report on like
the way they should CU it's like
watching actual like like the skin of a
human erode right and you're watching
like the skeleton start to show itself I
mean it's a total mess with all the
fentanyl coming through like millions of
pounds down there and it's just nonsense
and then uh no one's allowed to talk
about I went to the police station in
Yuma cuz I was getting the runaround
from the border patrol cuz they're
allowed to talk to you they pulled me
over a bunch for just being there really
yeah and then the police I'm like I'm
wondering what they think about this and
they're not allowed to talk to you they
were going to make me sign a form to at
least do a a right along to see the the
town with them my wife had to sign that
form but she had to be there I was in
Yuma my wife is in West Virginia like
they make it impossible for a journalist
to do it right the border patrol will
give you a press tour of all this stuff
but that's like you know what what to
expect from a press po you know that's
what AOC got when she cried yeah
meanwhile we have videos of actual
federal agents removing border barriers
all migrants to illegally enter the
country it's absolutely insane and when
you look at who's coming into the
country I've been I went down to Yuma in
20121 too and I was down there in the
summertime pretty hot you know pretty a
pretty treacherous Journey 116 degrees
in July treacherous Journey if you were
a refugee seeking Refuge but that I
didn't see any of those people I saw
guys that were my age and younger that
did not look like they had just treed
across the desert they were getting bust
right up there the whole thing I mean
you think like chaotic border scene
there's people like jumping Ross the
Border I saw a little bit of that but by
and large it was a very controlled flow
of people coming into the country and
and people don't think about like so
Yuma is a good example of how weird it
is because it's not like that giant Trek
people I think a lot of people imagine
going through the desert there's a
highway you can see through the wall
that you're getting dropped off at a lot
of people spend a lot of money to get
flown into the mexical airport then they
get driven to that Highway there's
people set up in tents along the highway
send you camouflage gear water
cigarettes you walk like 30 minutes to
the wall and then border patrols there
like TSA it's like soft TSA they got
water for you they got a tent they tag
your bags literally they got they had an
easier time talking to border patrol
than I did yeah when I was down there we
couldn't get Hotel I actually went down
there with representative Paul gosar and
his team and we couldn't get hotels in
Yuma because the federal government had
booked the vast majority of them for
illegal immigrants yeah it seemed like
such a controlled portal because the the
immigrants don't stay there either they
like they there they get they get uh
plane tickets bus tickets yes sent right
out yeah you go I mean there was people
tweeting coming I think coming home from
the TP USA event you guys yeah yeah she
was putting that stuff up but every time
I've flown into Arizona the last couple
years like on it's only been once or
twice but I've seen that exact same
thing she it's right up in your face
they're not hiding it she was going hard
after Delta and I'm like oh that sucks
because I really like Delta no I I
predict that Ashley stclair is bringing
down Delta and I I meant that as a
double in Tandra I'm sorry for people
who got mad at that but uh it I was like
is Delta trending because of her but the
videos were going around and it's good
people should know about it I mean when
I was I was a teacher in Westchester in
New York and they were flying illegal
immigrants into that airport yeah and
that's a small little area like you know
outside of the city do you guys remember
when uh the Biden admin was caught
trafficking children yeah this is this
is not even in dispute this is a fact
Joe Biden was engaged in human
trafficking I think that was actually
airport I'm talking about the
Westchester Airport that's right yep
it's insane and uh I think was it James
O'Keefe who who uh had the story someone
had a story where they no maybe it
wasn't James o'keef where they had
undercover video of one of the I I think
it was a border patrol guy being like if
the American people knew what we were
doing they would Revolt yeah Carrie Lake
shared a letter that she got with me
from a guy from border patrol and it was
like they've given up on the border here
the post he was at he's like there's
hours a day where it's not even
patrolled I don't think they've given up
that's their plan well yeah yeah he to
him he thinks they've given up right but
this is a controlled collapse is what it
seems like yeah maybe because they they
fully expect this country to be it in in
full scale conflict and who do you think
is going to fight against the American
people the people who want to be
receiving the benefits and privileges of
a country for which they are not
citizens I mean we got Senators that are
saying that we should put illegal
immigrants into the United States
military I think Los Angeles is trying
to make them police officers right now
illegal immigrant I mean just absolute
Insanity yeah it's depraved doesn't make
any sense but it does for them this is
like their log it's logical for what
they do all they care about is power
that's it they mean what they're doing
in Colorado what they're doing at the
border with the fent and all the only
thing they care about is raw political
power yes if you operate under the
assumption that they actually have a
plan to help America none of this makes
sense if you understand that their plan
is to destroy this country yep it all
makes sense 100% And then you just roll
out Biden and you can write off
everything to him just being old and
incompetent like oh yeah it's just Biden
he just kind of stumbles around like
there's they just must be kind of messed
up like no this is a very well Machine
it's delivered plan the argument that
they make is that it's it's replacement
population because Americans aren't
having enough kids and it's because we
need the the people working to be able
to uh keep the Ponzi scheme of Social
Security going that's the argument they
make right right yeah okay okay I mean
but
that war is
trending well I mean realistically this
is
legitimately you know whatever people
think about how often we talk about you
know Civil War here uh this is you know
it's history making it's it's
unprecedented um and they're so um
what's his name um yeah they're locking
up journalists we had Owen just got out
yeah the guy from The Blaze is about to
get go in well that was today actually
yeah let me take a look at his uh down
at at the America Fest I'm looking for
his name I forgot his name but that
actor who was arrested at the airport
after the lady Ballers uh Premiere like
the feds he was I guess at Jan 6 and the
FEDS had already dealt with him years
like three years ago and they went and
they arrested him at the airport after
going to the Daily wire Premiere I mean
all of this gives the regime a great
excuse to have another Biden red sermon
where he's like look you know these got
we can't trust them you know what they
did on January 6 like they're already
they're already moving that direction
but don't worry my Administration has it
under control it's it's insane because
when he was running for president if are
you was running Loosely like KLA staff
was donating money to get arsonist bail
money you know like they were severely
encouraging violence there was that
mayor out in maybe Portland went to the
capital or the courthouse burning I
forget his name I always forget his name
but there's that crazy yeah that crazy
video of him like bathing in the smoke
like he was getting baptized he was
trying to pretend like he was going down
there and like he he attempted to be
cool with antifa and they attacked him
then they tried to burn his condo down
it's like they're not going to be your
friends Ted you're not cool you might as
well just crack down him but he's still
to this day he's he's attempting to
appease those people mostly because he's
a coward yeah clearly yeah yeah they did
like a lock in in his ba or in his like
Lobby or something yeah he lived in one
of those highrises downtown and they
basically like tried to light the whole
thing on fire so Steve Baker does not
have to surrender apparently it's been
reported that he won't have to surrender
until after Christmas okay but still
surrendering yeah sheesh his self-
surrender would be postponed until after
Christmas and the justice department has
assigned a new a USA oh to his case you
know Tucker made a really great point
the other night when he
said what someone's going to saying no
and that that's another component of
Civil War yeah mhm know yeah how long
was it like 10 no no no it how was it 10
years ago or longer remember that family
in New Hampshire didn't want to pay
taxes and so they just like locked their
doors and then the feds showed up and
surrounded the building and it was like
this really crazy thing I don't know so
it was a wild story that happened I
think at the end of the 2000s or
something like that well nobody really
cares it's one family refusing to pay
taxes but this stuff is every day what
happens when you get one by one by one
people just saying no yeah I mean there
was that one guy remember that one guy
who they shot and killed he was the
morbidly obese elderly man yeah who was
posting yeah stupid crap on5 years old
or whatever guy could be and so they did
a whatever a pre-dawn raid and kicked in
his door like you need to send the entry
team to the 75 they already talked to
the guy too like they knocked on his
door and talked to him give me a break
so Frank luns posted this just recently
Colorado has proven Trump's theory true
that he is the victim of political
persecution his poll numbers won't drop
on the contrary they will rise that kind
of is worth noting Frank Lun is not a
pro Trump kind of dude at all and if he
can even see that this is proving Trump
right like so there there was an
argument to be made that you know
obviously I was I was convinced that
that they were after Trump you know
after January after January 6 as soon as
the the impeachment stuff was going on I
was convinced they were after Trump but
that being said like someone like Frank
Lun to openly acknowledge it um I mean
that that that that says something about
you know what people are are going to
see when they look at the situation you
hear the Democrats talk about democracy
constantly and it is clear that they are
not interested in democracy and this
really I don't see how you can make the
argument that they that they are with a
straight face you know thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast C hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net